[Music]
oh
blessed be thy day for it is 90 day
fiance time
yes yes yes yes yes my favorite
i love it so much they are so crazy
are there any sane couples in the world
apparently not apparently not
so today we're looking at mr paul
i think that's his name he's going to
brazil to meet the love
of his wife love of his life
english sorry i don't even speak the
same native language that's never going
to work
my other concern is he's already very
optimistic
i'm doing this but it's never going to
work queen's hometown is so remote
you can't drive to it the only way to
get there
is to fly into a main city and that's
not a big deal a river
for several days oh what
where did he find this [ __ ] how did
they have internet there
how what what is his love story
i'm leaving in two days to make this
huge journey to brazil
nice oh wow he prepped a lot of
plan i got four standard military foot
lockers
one standard military duffel bag and my
carry-on
in case the war breaks out paul is ready
no problem
a heat vest to help deal with the
temperature we're down there
it's a head wrap to help heat stroke or
heat exhaustion as you do you
you bring those of course
various types of uh water filters better
to have it and not need it than needed
to not have it
so i brought every single thing that you
could bring jesus christ
he's bought all this product right into
the issue of the parasitic fish
that actually subtracted human urine and
actually splunk your urethra
nice doctor told me to basically take a
standard condom
and uh delicately secure it to myself
without cutting out circulation of
course then it would come men went to
the doctor
to go hey i'm going to brazil i heard
there's
fishes that swim up your peepee doctor
what can i
do man just put on a condom you dumb
if you're that scared doctor on the off
chance that a fish will swim up my
peepee
what do i do he really did prepare for
everything
better to look like an idiot and be
protected than uh i don't know
i don't know if that statement is true
you're gonna wear this every day
only the fill is necessary when does it
feel necessary
paul what a guy is that what he's gonna
wear when he
gets introduced to their parents hey
nice to meet you
there doesn't have to be any pee-pee
swimming uh fish around here
yeah do you have fish in the yard or is
it
okay are you a peepee swimming fish this
looks very promising
it's always a gamble with these you know
is that the foreigner that's gonna be
the psychopath or is it the
uh the local one that's gonna be a
psychopath are they both psychopaths
well it's the morning we'll just have to
wait and see you never know
there's many plots and turns very very
anxious
very nervous not sure what to expect my
anxiety level is
pretty high why would your anxiety be
level be high you're
you're literally prepared for every
single thing
that could happen this heavy uh two can
be a hundred pounds three can be 70
pounds
i hope this is the last two heavy ones
yeah these are too heavy
i think you should leave a lot of this
stuff there these two cases aren't
coming back
good my mother's taking me to the
airport she's feeling extremely
emotional about me leaving
what this is a doctor um
she actually just uh snuck out and gave
me a little bit of her hair from her
comb to take with her
what it means a lot uh what that's
actually something it's
it's her hair what what happened
what yeah oh that came out of nowhere
man you can't just what
um
what okay i can with confidence say
here's the psychopath got it very sweet
her to do something like that for me
i'll make sure i pack it in here
actually dude man my mama name
gave me a piece of her hair before a
trip my mama sucks sorry mama i'm sorry
you were great i'm just kidding
what does he do with the hair i have so
many i cannot let that slide what does
he do with the hair
i don't understand i don't know paul oh
my god
i hope it's all right i really do
all right here we go
i can't deal with this i can't let it go
why why did the mom give her hair
yeah why sure no change in your mind
this is definitely crazy i'm freaking
out over here
i'd rather go to my death bed saying hey
i did this hey i did that
and man i could have done this and i
could have done that hey paul said
something good
that i agree with how about that i agree
with mr urethra
mom's hair paul but yeah i agree it's
better take a chance
you don't want to live life not knowing
what if challenge yourself
get out there do stuff don't always pick
the comfortable rap
that's literally what i thought to
myself before i met marcy i was like
because i was terrified before going to
italy i'm like yeah i gotta go for it i
gotta see this through
you
just to get because future self will
thank you
future felix pass felix you're welcome
i love kentucky
several day boat journey to get to
korea's hometown
how are we going to do this paul yeah
men prepared for everything you didn't
think how he was going to carry all his
luggage
all right i've never left the country
but i can tell i'm back now i can tell
you could get one of those cards you
know you don't have to take them one at
a time
i guess he's never been at an airport
before oh my god well at least he has
his mom's hair
i can't wait to keep watching this this
is beautiful
wait now we took a bit of a jump what
happened to the whole journey there all
right well i guess that's
cutting the brazilian future fiance
future hotel
you can tell we missed a little bit of
in between here but uh you can tell he
left a good impact
on the family daddy is really happy
about mr urethra
over here oh my god that look
holy sh he is so done with it paul
already what happened i need to know
this is what i get for watching youtube
instead of the whole episodes call me
i actually asked her parents permission
said carini
to a a hotel um to stay with me
but based on facial expressions this is
definitely not going well right about
now
no no no no no
[Music]
why is she not speaking oh
i i have a million questions she doesn't
speak to him she
writes on the phone what i take your
daughter to have sex with her in a
motel wait they don't speak the same
language so she
types oh
which is ironic because i'm not looking
to rush in anything like that right now
with greeny
in the past sex definitely caused drama
and problems for me
but it seems like it's the list okay
just understand okay i'm sorry we'll
just say here that's not what i mean
i'm sorry but that's not the phase i
that would make me reassure that they're
not going to go to the hotel if
and have bing bong bing bong if that was
what bothered me
that is not helping oh god this is so
cringe
yeah i promise to keep her on her
look at this dude
all right that's a fair answer god damn
it i want karini oh yes
yes look at the title ever worn a condom
to go swimming
before we get physical but i want us to
have some fun together
before i bring that up
he wanted he want to drop the the big
head question the std question
it did not go over well last couple
[Music]
seven yes here really yeah
really here oh no urethra
my urethra help me help me help me no
you swim in there
[Music]
he knows you don't understand
you don't understand the doctor warn me
they're gonna swim
or swim in any untreated water because
of all the diseases
oh you're gonna jump in aren't you
but i definitely want to impress granny
oh she's impressed
trust me she's very impressed
how could she not beat this on first he
said fish gets to the waiter and i had
this little
what is that i guess like a sheath
protection bag
i put a condom on have that to hold that
on definitely no one
nothing's pointing at my penis
why do you need two i am so confused
all right wait what he's wearing pants
so he's i wanna impress
kareena so therefore
okay so she just speak to him by the way
why is he wearing a life jacket as well
can you not swim
i'm not man is like ready for zombie
apocalypse i swear to god
i definitely want to impress karine
what's up in plastic trousers
orange vest oh probably the first time
this man has ever knew hey
come on come on but to impress her
it's dressed like a sock how did the
camera
keep live filming i would have thought i
were laughing
oh my god what a couple
oh oh no urethra he's got it
[Applause]
poop water
a little it embarrass you a little
oh man all right here we come to
how will kareem react to paul confessing
his mysterious past
what happened what did paul do in his
past
i can't wait to see this i'm nervous
that when carini
finds out about kyrie sorry i just
walk away like all the other women did
oh
he's got a dirty little secret well it
can't be anything sex
related we know that he's talking over
the phone now
[Music]
you need to know that i'm a convicted
criminal i've been to jail i'm being in
jail oh okay
for what begs the question right
for what she's like dude everyone around
here everyone
it's no problem i've been in jail i've
been in prison
for uh numerous things numerous things
numerous i was accused of burning my own
house
and bringing my own personal property
what and
spent about 18 months in jail
for burning your own property and had a
straining order from an ex-girlfriend
oh my god and then a few years ago
i was in a very terrible relationship
she took out emergency character we're
on me
i'm sorry jeez
i'm sorry i mean that's at least he's
honest about it i respect that i guess
oh she doesn't deserve damaged goods
it's not fair to her oh
he seemed to really take it hard on
himself
that's garbage right don't leave
those
i need my space right now i need to walk
away for a little bit
cream she's like what the [ __ ] just
happened
does not deserve to have someone like me
that's constantly has
problems around her so
what is happening then why are you
dating her
and why did you come here you're just
being all mopey popey right now and it's
really awkward and weird
i can't be with her he's running stop
him not gonna work
stop him
don't go there paul there's fishes there
i swear
oh my god oh where did he go
i need more of that clip i am not going
to sit by and not
watch more what happens i gotta find the
full okay i found this but it has
she's just laughing
[Music]
oh my god what is happening
don't take his urethra protection this
is so weird
i finally confessed he created my
criminal record i couldn't handle her
reaction
well you ran before she even got the
chance to react what the hell
oh god paul this is the greatest couple
of all time
i love it
karine tells our parents she's not happy
i can't
um she said that
the problem is when her parents gone
you just became a other person
and you said that she couldn't
talk to other people only romantically
rather than she'd talk to anybody she
wants to
i just don't want to talk to anybody
where it has intimacy involved that's it
i understand she wants to talk to her
family and friends
but when she talks to other men i mean
i would have a problem with that too but
i don't know what the messages were
what's that about what are those emojis
handsome friends okay i mean
is it wrong to stereotype that people
are a bit flurry flirch
flirtatious in brazil is that a is that
a
i don't know if that's correct or not
but uh yeah i don't have a problem with
that would you yeah
yeah would you mind yeah don't just
laugh it out handsome no she ain't
calling other guys handsome [ __ ] you
yeah i'm on pulse side now i complete
180 out of nowhere
[Music]
sometimes you don't listen to her
and you make her cry yeah that's a big
flaw
i can't do that i think sometimes
i unintentionally treat cranny in a way
that she really doesn't deserve to be
treated
she's still learning and i get
frustrated okay i'm back on hey i hate
paul
train now i wish i'd go back and i could
change those things but i can't
ah man you gotta sort yourself out first
man
insecure men are the most dangerous kind
of people i'm not that secure
but yeah he's acting super weird around
her
has kareem being cheating on paul and is
she pregnant things are just not going
well
we'll find out next episode i'll have to
split this in two
parts hell yeah beautiful thanks for
watching this episode if you enjoyed
leave a like and subscribe 106 million
subs let's
get it let's get it i'll see you guys
tomorrow ah
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean